la question des retraites monsieur
premier ministre est désormais à
l'assemblée nationale elle concerne tous
les français
les intéressent les préoccupent faute de
réponse beaucoup d'interrogations
demeurent les contestations restent
multiples vous imposer aux députés de
travailler sur un texte sans financement
vous n'écoutez rien votre dossier n'est
pas prêt la franche gronde le pays
fronde sur vos orientations
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi un
tel entêtement alors que l'on connaît
les gens jus du dossier en l'état
monsieur le premier ministre
l'assemblée nationale est entravé dans
sa fonction législative
le nombre de femmes dont les emplois
auront été précaires sous payés à temps
partiel en horaires décalés avec des
interruptions pour élever des enfants
pour accompagner un proche dans la
maladie un parent enfants porteurs de
handicap ou enfin pour cause de chômage
dispose de petites retraites
le système universel à points que vous
proposez prendra en compte toutes les
périodes travaillées et non plus les 25
meilleures années où les derniers six
mois pour la fonction publique
c'est un changement radical pour les
femmes en particulier puisque les
mauvaises années seront désormais prises
en compte pour le calcul de leur pension
ou maltraiter les avocats comme vous
maltraitez les français
faut-il que je vous rappelle que plus de
95% des 163 barreau de notre beau pays
ont reconduit leur mouvement en votant
qui une grève illimitée qui une grève
reconductible qui une grève du zèle
stop à la recherche du bouc émissaire ce
ne sont pas les avocats qui paralyse la
justice c'est notre projet de loi
retraites
les avocats savent qu'avec cette réforme
leur indépendance sera compromise leur
liberté d'exercer comme ils l'entendent
seul ou en cabinet étoffé sera
compromise leur liberté n'est-elle pas
l'une des garanties de l'indépendance de
la justice
il y a quinze ans le président jacques
chirac faisait voter un texte fondateur
pour l'égalité des droits et des chances
des personnes handicapées
rendons lui hommage nous voulons que
chacun puisse faire de ces différences
et de ses propres talents la force de sa
vie il y a urgence
combien de nouvelles places d'accueil
annoncé vous de quels moyens nouveaux
disposez-vous
les républicains avec damien abad
aurélien pradié ont fait des
propositions et travail tankers
mais nous n'avons pas été associés à
cette conférence madame la ministre
et nous le regrettons tous les chiffres
de la délinquance sont en train de
passer au rouge et vous êtes bien le
seul à ne pas son bien être inquiété ces
résultats vous impose une forte remise
en question seriez-vous prêt à reprendre
enfin les propositions que les
républicains vous font depuis plusieurs
années pour rompre avec le laxisme
pénale de madame taubira et combattre
plus durablement la délinquance et le
terrorisme islamiste
quand allez-vous rétablir les peines
planchers pour sanctionner réellement
les récidivistes
quand allez-vous placés en rétention de
sûreté des djihadistes sortie de prison
est un dispositif visant à adapter la
création de sites internet mutualisés
pour la vente en ligne de médicaments et
ce sont donc autant de professionnels de
santé en moins notamment dans les
territoires ruraux où le pharmacien
d'officine est le plus souvent le
dernier acteur de santé au service de la
population
jusqu'où le gouvernement tente ils
allaient dans l'élimination progressive
de ces acteurs de santé de proximité
[Musique]